welcome to the David Pakman show I am of
course not David Pakman I'm Benjamin
Dixon host of the Benjamin Dixon show
David is away on vacation I believe
which is a well-deserved break from all
of the political madness there are a lot
of things happening in the news I want
to start with Nike making Colin
Kaepernick the face of their new ad will
pull the image up on your screen now and
on that on this new ad this says this
believe in something even if even if it
means sacrificing everything just do it
now as you can imagine conservatives
have already started to lose their mind
and before we revel in all of them
burning their Nike apparel let's get a
few details about this deal so
apparently this is a superstar deal
where he gets roughly a million dollars
or more a year plus royalties and this
is a significant deal because Nike has
been supporting Colin Kaepernick since
2011 all the way through this process
now what makes this deal important and
even bigger is that it places Colin
Kaepernick in even more direct
competition and confrontation with the
NFL as well as President Trump it's it's
almost as if Nike is giving him and even
even larger platform than he already had
and by them supporting him it really
puts a bind on the NFL now in the
situation with the NFL taking a knee and
the potential collusion that took place
between NFL owners to keep Colin
Kaepernick out of off the football field
has taken a turn last week a judge ruled
that the case could continue and so now
this is like two weeks in a row where
there has been a lot of negative
information and negative results for the
NFL and Colin Kaepernick appears to be
winning in several different ways that
being the case I want to read a quote
here from the New York Times and this is
what they had to say about it
they said quote
Nike will produce new Kapernick apparel
including shoe and a t-shirt and if the
merchandise sales well the value of the
deal will rival those of other top NFL
players according to the people close to
the negotiations who spoke on the
conditions of anonymity because Nike had
not formed and formally announced it
Naik will also donate money to cap annex
quote know your rights campaign now this
is an important factor in this anyone
who who knows anything about Nike
understands Nikes history with
sweatshops and child labor and unsavory
business practices both here in the
United States but particularly across
the globe and this is bringing a lot of
attention to to the reality of
corporations co-opting movements social
movements co-opting the radical voices
that are speaking out against political
and economic power ultimately it's an
example of what we on the Left would say
capitalism co-opting a movement this is
capitalism protecting yourself but but
under underneath this you have to take
note of what Colin Kaepernick is doing
with his wealth Colin Kaepernick has
donated millions of dollars to activists
locally who are fighting against police
brutality systemic and justices etc etc
and so Colin Kaepernick is taking this
money from Nike as in in addition to
living his life because I mean chances
are he you know we all had to be
wondering how he's surviving he's not
getting a check anymore you know he
wasn't in the league long enough to be
set up forever you know most players
take a long time to get enough wealth to
be able to walk away from the league and
many players don't ever make enough
because of their spending habits but the
point is this is that Colin Kaepernick
needed this he needed this in this
revenue this income to survive but in
addition to survival
Kaepernick uses this money for good so I
mean there's a lot of conversations
about whether or not whether or not we
should be happy about this I'm
indifferent towards Nike but what I will
say is that I'm all
for colin kaepernick using his wealth
the way that he uses it which is to one
speak out against power speak truth to
power and then to fund local activists
who are actually on the ground doing the
work now something positive like this
will not happen without conservative
backlash and I want to read you a couple
of tweets from conservatives who lost
their minds the first one here on
Twitter says this first the NFL forces
me to choose between my favorite sport
and my country
I choose country then Nike forces me to
choose between my favorite shoes and my
country so when did the American flag
and the national anthem become offensive
now I wanted to read you that tweet from
someone who seems to be just a random
Twitter user because he shared video
with it take a look at this video here
I'm on joy hell I might buy go buy some
adidas hmm you know how many other
sneakers are to buy to choose from there
to go ahead you're gonna go ahead and
say hey buy him our shoes we stand with
people who kneel for the national anthem
well sorry Nike I've been buying you for
the past 20 plus years not anymore
not only am i burning my favorite pair
of Nikes you are burning your sails have
a good day I mean you know it's it's
ridiculous people make these scenes and
obviously their publicity stunts they
want attention and so they burn their
apparel they did this win when LeBron
James and up the Cleveland Cavaliers and
that trend never ended but the reality
of it is is that Nike doesn't care about
the handful of people they've already
made the calculation this is a business
decision for Nike they have already
calculated the cost how much they're
going to lose from conservatives who are
mad and how much when they make up in
terms of people who are like hmm Nikes
doing something good with all of the
products from their sweatshops so maybe
I'll go and buy some shoes and we'll
talk about that later but the point is
is that this is a business decision by
Nike and so they know full well exactly
about how many people they're gonna lose
they know their demographic they know
their target demographic they understand
that they're gonna lose X amount of
dollars but they're gonna make up so
much more or else they would not have
done this deal I don't believe that Nike
is doing anything out of the goodness of
their heart let's just let's dispense
with that notion their Nike is not
sacrificing anything in this deal Nike
is going to make money with this deal
and that's the point the the other point
obviously is that Colin Kaepernick isn't
going to make money with this deal and
he has demonstrated that he's going to
continue to do good with the money that
he makes so you know while conservatives
are losing their mind burning all of
their apparel the reality of it is is
Nike doesn't doesn't really care but I
want to read this from conservatives
favorite black conservative voice these
days
Candis Owens on Twitter this is what she
had to say she said quote
congratulations to adidas for a
wonderful win in business today they are
proof that sometimes all you have to do
is sit back and let your competitors
shoot themselves in the [ __ ] and in the
foot hashtag three stripe life at adidas
at adidas USA and at adidas underscore
UK no underscore there yeah
okay if you say so and the only reason I
read that besides the silliness of it is
that you know in my effort to find a
conflict-free
sneaker adidas was listed there but
adidas was listed there as and as a more
eco-friendly sneaker and as I research
the adidas is there and and I know this
is not Candace's perspective I don't
really care about our perspective but
just adidas in in general and in my
efforts to find conflict-free shoes
shoes that pay a living wage there
literally are no popular shoes on the
market today that pay their workers a
livable wage including adidas but it's
adidas is listed as a more eco-friendly
shoe that was something fascinating that
I saw this morning so a lot of people
most of us in the United States we are
consumers of conflict goods it is it's
just what it is and so you know while
people are lamenting this deal with Nike
and you know where you gonna go
I guarantee you most of you got have
Nike in your closets or in your you know
your jogging apparel or whatnot but one
more of course it would not be a
complete day without ben shapiro
chiming in and this is what he had to
say with regard to colin kaepernick
sacrifice this is what he had to say he
said quote name the thing he sacrificed
he was bench before he protested he
became he's become far more celebrated
and famous than his performance would
justify now that he's got a lucrative ad
contract Ali sacrificed something
Kaepernick didn't now this comment is
very important because it demonstrates
you to you exactly what conservatives
have done through American history they
will first of all pick two black people
against each other to try to make their
point but that's just the surface level
if you go one level deeper they are
always willing to lift up somebody after
they're dead as a as the paragon of the
way you know as the the quintessential
example of how you should
or how you should protest oh you should
do it like dr. King did it well you know
we would see how dr. King would do it
today if you all didn't kill him and it
speaks to the whitewashing of their
relationship conservatives relationship
with people who protest power they are
always willing to say oh yeah we
definitely would have done it you know
like Ali Ali really sacrificed something
but how many people actually think that
ben shapiro would be on the side of a
radical black muslim a radical black man
who was Muslim
a part of the Nation of Islam you know
Vince Shapiro is lifting up Ali just to
sandbag Colin Kaepernick when in reality
he would not have been on either side he
hated them just the same so it's just a
standard ploy by conservatives to pit
black people against each other to pit
revolutionaries against each other to
pit progressives against each other
knowing full well that there's no
iteration of protest that any of us can
do I don't care if you're black if
you're white if you're protesting
political power then there's no way that
you could protest and have it approved
by those people in power power will
never approve of your protest it doesn't
matter if you kneel it doesn't matter if
you sit quietly as in a sit-in it
doesn't matter if you are quiet in class
and you silent and refuse to speak it
doesn't matter if you're marching in the
streets it doesn't matter if you're
standing in front of a building there's
no way that you can protest that will
ever be approved of by the system and no
matter how they like to throw people
from the past into the mix to say oh
this is how dr. King would do it or this
is how Muhammad Ali would do it the fact
of the matter is is that they would have
opposed them during their time the same
way they opposed Colin Kaepernick right
now